bist du so richtig zufrieden wird deinem
garten also ist das ein richtiger
hingucker garten zu garten also meiner
jedenfalls nicht immer liegt er
überzeugt alles irgendwie zweckmäßig und
irgendwie nehme ich mir oft auch gar
nicht die zeit um den garten schön zu
machen weil es immer nur darum geht dass
er produktiv ist aber damit ist jetzt
schluss das auge isst schließlich mit
ich habe letztes jahr schon damit
angefangen und ein paar richtig richtig
coole projekte in meinem garten
umgesetzt das zeige ich euch also gleich
noch wir gehen gleich noch mal in den
garten und machen eine kleine tour aber
jetzt zeige ich euch nicht mal so ein
paar ideen die ich gesammelt habe wo ich
richtig heiß darauf werden die jetzt im
neuen jahr im garten umzusetzen wir
fangen mit torbögen bzw sind keine tor
bin ist hinzu rankgerüst bögen kennt ihr
die die sieht man oft auf youtube oder
auch auf pintos die ursprünglich kenne
ich die von dem youtube-kanal erhitzen
refuge formen ich weiß nicht wie die
kennt richtig toller kanal ich mache
hier mal das video anderen können wir
uns das zusammen anschauen die frau
heißt es und die hat so so schöne
transocean ihrem garten ich überlege wie
ich das bei mir umsetzen kann weil
erstens weiß ich nicht was für metall
man in deutschland neben soll in amerika
nehmen die kette panel aber soweit ich
weiß sind die in deutschland nicht so
bieck war das kondom dazu wenn das
irgendwer was hat mir das gerne so ich
bin da schon seit mehreren jahren heiß
drauf und hab das nie umgesetzt weil ich
nicht weiß was für einen pittermann
nehmen kann das biegsam ist aber nicht
zufällig ich hab auch eine richtig tolle
idee of interest gefunden wie man das
aus holz machen kann nicht endlich mal
vor man läuft er durch und dann hängen
da überall die kurden oder die kürbisse
runter oder stangenbohnen dass es doch
mega schön ist auch richtig cooler bogen
das ist einfach so spitz oben zu häufig
das war vielleicht auch für meinen
garten mal gucken ihr werdet von
irgendwann sehen weil ich werde das hier
nicht nur erzählen wie ich will das auch
wirklich umsetzen wir schleppen immer
das ganze geerntete gemüse nach hause
und waschen das in unserem waschbecken
und dann ist die ganze erde einfach
neben waschbecken drin dabei könnte man
doch eigentlich eine wasserstation im
garten macht wenn das wasser dann auch
wieder auffangen kann zum gießen da habe
ich ja auch richtig coole ideen gefunden
auch so ein tisch mit guitar wo man dann
mit dem gartenschlauch die sachen
abbrausen kann dann schon man hier die
leitungen im haus und kann das wasser
eben noch mal wieder verwenden immer und
dann hätte ich so gern eine antwort ich
habe ja jeden mut hat ein anzug video
gemacht es ist ja und ja ich frage mich
ein bisschen warum ich nicht viel früher
auf die idee gekommen bin dass es super
cool wer so einen tisch zu haben weil
wir praktisch ist das wenn man zb eine
schublade auf machen kann dass die ganze
erde drin und man hat das alles parat
man hat hier seine krieg falls oder
angst auch köpfchen da die labels und
den stift eine richtig coole idee oder
ja ich habe einfach so richtig schön das
bild gefunden so einen komposter die
einfach aus stämmen holzstämmen gebaut
ist mein garten da sind überall
holzstämme das seht ihr gleich noch und
wenn ein neuer kompost einzieht dann
natürlich so eine hallo jetzt kommt
wieder was was ziemlich cool ist zum
organisieren zb von werkzeugen und
garten equipment das liegt bei mir im
moment immer noch überall rum und es
ärgert mich und deswegen stelle ich mir
das so vor dass jemand an suchte steht
und dann habe ich hier so eine wand mit
solo-platten wo man dann eben werkzeuge
aufhängen kann dann mag ich nach viel
mehr ran gerüste bauen da habe ich dann
schon sehr viel spaß dran an den rand
gerissen ich find die geben dem garten
irgendwie noch eine struktur die geben
dem höhe die machen das ist ordentlich
aussieht und da habe ich eine richtig
tolle idee gefunden wo man so holzrahmen
baut und dann dann gitter dazwischen
macht zum beispiel für erbsen und ich
glaube dass es einfach sehr sehr
ordentlich aussieht im garten moment
denke ich immer so stöcke schreck und
dann wieder in die andere richtung
streikt das sieht auch sehr cool aus
aber irgendwie wenn ich sowas sehe dann
will ich das einfach auch mal
ausprobieren wie das ist und dann
werde ich jetzt gerade wieder es ist
apple zu lagern im keller wir haben die
nun so pappkartons und kennen die nicht
übereinander stapeln weil die kartons
schon durchhängen in der mitte und dann
hängen die oberen level auf den unteren
äpfeln und das ist auf jeden fall super
nervig und ich freue mich schon sehr
lange
von dass ich irgendwann mal so ein kennt
ihr diese regale für den kellerräumen
die app frei machen kann und daraus
ziehen und auch sich so eine kartoffel
miete das seien auf jeden fall coole
bauprojekte aber so was findet man
vielleicht auch gebraucht auf ebay
kleinanzeigen oder im gebrauchtwaren
zentrum oder so da werde ich auf jeden
fall die augen offen halten aber
nächstes jahr muss auf jeden fall so ein
ding hier weil dieses jahr bin ich so
und relativ frustriert an der apfel
front das macht nicht so viel spaß wenn
man die nicht gut lagern kann unser
keller ist sowieso so folgere im bild
das da nicht viel platz ist um auch noch
jede einzelne apfel steige 1 in irgendwo
hinzustellen und dann kommt natürlich
auch noch mein cooler neuer hühnerstall
der wird so ein bisschen aussehen wie
sie per wohnwagen da freue ich mich
schon mega drauf da habe ich euch ja
schon mal von erzählt dass er gerade in
planung ist weil wenn es mit einem
schreiner zusammen machen damit viel
baupläne für euch erstellen können damit
ihr euch auch so coole kleine bauwagen
hühnerställe bauen könnte und ich glaube
das wird auf jeden fall ein richtiger
hingucker also das wird so ein richtig
richtig richtig schöner hühnerstall und
auch noch richtig durchdacht also wir
haben uns da so viele gedanken gemacht
was wohin kommt damit dass praktisch ist
damit man das ganz leicht ausmisten kann
damit die kinder sich darin wohlfühlen
übrigens war auch gerade in arbeit es
ist das gemüse garten bootcamp da bin
ich gerade schon fleißig am machen und
tun und filme und lernen damit ich
diesen mini kurs für euch erstellen kann
für diejenigen die vielleicht neu sind
auf meinem kanal und das noch nicht
mitbekommen haben ich erstelle jedes
jahr einen gemüsegarten mini kurs das
sind meistens drei videos die einen auf
das neue gartenjahr vorbereiten sollen
und einfach dafür sorgen sollen dass sie
einen viel besseren start in das neue
gartenjahr hab da planen wir auch
zusammen und räumen zusammen aber es
geht auch viel an die umsetzung eines
beete anlegen ich zeige da auch wie man
zum beispiel meine kompass beete anlegt
die zeige ich euch gleich noch im garten
aber das ist sehr praktisch weil die
jahrelang nahezu unkrautfrei bleiben
super ordentlich aussehen bis vielleicht
im kontext dieses videos gar nicht so
uninteressant und eben im ersten jahr
schon einen richtig guten ertrag
abwerfen also meldet euch da gerne für
an das ist wie gesagt völlig kostenlos
ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau wann es
losgeht aber tragt euch auf jeden fall
schon mal ein dann bekommt ihr per e
mail bescheid wenn es losgeht und
entsteht auch immer eine ganz tolle
gemeinschaft ist es ein richtig richtig
schöne art um das neue gartenjahr zu
starten der link ist würde ich sagen man
hier oben und unten in der
videobefragung wir jetzt gegenüber raus
und schauen uns an was für projekte ich
da im letzten jahr schon umgesetzt habe
ich bin schon ein bisschen stolz richtig
zu zeigen let's go das erste bauprojekt
wenn man in den garten reinkommt ist
dieser wunderschöne torbogen den haben
wir aus haselnuss holz gebaut und zwar
mit holzmöbeln also da an dem ding ist
keine einzige schraube und kein einziger
nagel drin sind alles holz dübel und da
wächst im sommer meine kiwi wäre hoch
und auch ein kürbis und stangenbohnen
und hin dass ein richtig schöner eingang
für den garten und das ist auch ein
bauprojekt was man einem wochenende gut
bewältigen kann komplett aus natürlichen
materialien und dann haben wir hier
diese kleinen zäune geflochten als die
umrandung jetzt ist natürlich gerade
winter und alles sieht irgendwie total
gut aus aber im sommer war das unfassbar
schön auch mit dem salbei der hier so
rüber wächst und davon will ich auf
jeden fall noch viel mehr machen und
damit so kleine abgrenzungen im garten
schaffen und ja da bin ich auf jeden
fall sehr stolz darauf und das hat
wahnsinnig viel spaß gemacht die zu
flechten und dann nicht zu übersehen
natürlich das gewächshaus gewechselte
können auch richtig schön sein das war
natürlich auch entsprechend teuer aber
ich finde es definiert auf jeden fall
diesen garten das haben wir schon länger
als ein jahr ist ich glaube jetzt zwei
drei jahre steht das hier und ich bin
super super happy damit dann habe ich ja
dieses wunderschöne regal im gewächshaus
die idee habe ich auch auf interest
geklaut und jetzt ist es gerade relativ
leer aber im sommer ist das super
praktisch wenn man da zum beispiel
jünger drin hat hornspäne wall pellets
urgesteins metern dann einfach mit der
schaufel immer rausholen kann was man
braucht ansonsten habe ich hier auch ein
paar werkzeuge und dann habe ich hier
noch eine halterung für rang stellte
also alle möglichen rankhilfen die ich
so habe die jetzt nicht so riesig lang
sind die kann man dann hier aufbewahren
um ist auch alles ganz organisiert der
ist jetzt an ist besonders schön aus
aber im sommer war das der hamas die
hohen sind hat jetzt schon relativ tod
ich muss mal die letzten noch abernten
aber hier haben wir so ein zelt
aufgebaut und da ganz viel mit weile
drumrum geflochten und hier oben ist
auch geflochten ich weiß nicht immer das
sieht und das war jetzt einen stangen
grünsfeld und ich fand das richtig toll
weil das dem garten noch mal so viel
höher gibt eine struktur und ja ich bin
ganz beliebt
dann habe ich hier meine erste die habe
ich auch schon ein paar jahre länger
aber das ist richtig praktisch da haben
wir immer waschmaschinentrommel in den
boden ein diejenigen von euch die in
meinem obst und gemüse haltbar machen
kurz mit dabei sind haben wir auch viele
von euch haben solche trommeln weil wir
da die bauanleitung drin haben und da
lagen jetzt zum beispiel die kartoffeln
karotten kann man darin lagern auch cool
und lauch und das ist wirklich richtig
praktisch und die kann man sehr leicht
selber bauen aus alten waschmaschinen
trommeln kriegt man zb auf ebay
kleinanzeigen ziemlich günstig dann habe
ich alle beete mit solchen holzstämmen
hier eingefasst das finde ich auch total
schön es ist auch sehr praktisch gerade
wenn man die compass beete hat die wir
ja anlegen dass meine kleine beet
umrandung hat dass das gras nicht von
außen rein wachsen kann weil die beete
die bleiben ja von sich aus sehr
unkrautfrei aber von außen würde das
gras ist eben schon einfach in die beete
wieder reinwachsen deswegen brauchen wir
hier eine abgrenzung und dafür eignet
sich holz stimme richtig gut und ich
finde diesen auch richtig schön aus ein
richtig cooles bauprojekt ist auch und
vögel kasten gerade für die die
vielleicht keinen gewächshaus bauen
können oder wollen da kann man nämlich
im winter immer noch ganz viele leckere
gemüse anbauen und auch im frühling viel
früher ehren das ist auf jeden fall eine
super sache man kann die auf hochbeete
darauf montieren oder auch auf ihr mehr
die gebete so dass man die da drauf
stellen kann und dann im sommer einfach
wieder abbauen war es auch eine richtig
schöne idee ist um pflanzen zu
beschriften ist wenn man alte scherben
aufhebt und da dann einfach mit edding
drauf schreibt das hält jahre lang und
so bin ich gar nicht mehr so traurig
wenn der tassen teller runter fällt
gerade wenn sie besonders schön sind
weil sie eben auch sehr tolle pflanze
aktiven war es natürlich nicht fehlen
darf wenn ein garten schön sein soll
sind blumen davon habe ich jetzt im
winter eher weniger aber ich bleibe euch
mal hier bilder ein ja ich bin
eigentlich eher so der typ der jeden
zentimeter in beet für gemüse einplant
oder sachen die man auch essen kann
aber in letzter zeit bin ich schon auch
sehr begeistert wenn es ein bisschen
hübsch ist ein bisschen blöd und es gibt
ja auch viele blumen die man essen kann
und deswegen fange ich auch immer mehr
an den garten mit blumen zu gestalten
das macht auch sehr viel spaß und ist
noch mal eine ganz andere art von
gärtnern was auch richtig schön ist und
ein garten ja irgendwie als lebenswert
macht sind in dem man sich ausruhen kann
sitzecken gemütliche ecken und das tier
geht absolut nicht auf meine kappe
sondern auf die von unseren vermietern
die haben es hier nämlich richtig schön
gemacht im garten und da trieben
verlinke ich euch ein video wo es darum
geht welche garten größer am besten zu
einem passt also da habe ich so ein
richtiges kurs erstellt das könnt ihr
durch gehen und am ende stirbt es euch
die garten größer aus die am besten zu
eurem leben euren bedürfnissen passt
also schaut auf jeden fall gerne da
vorbei und dann geht raus und macht eure
gärten ein bisschen schöner oder viel
schöner und tücke wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 für sie hieß